Alex can you tell us where you were in
your life before American History X
before the audition and what you went
through to book this role as Mitch
McCormick okay well first of all I was
broke I had no no no no money no
driver's license I was living in
mid-wilshire I was in a very bad spot I
had been acting now about five or five
years at this point five or six years I
had not had any auditions for film yet I
had only gone to do things in like the
theater things through the drama-logue
backstage West and whatnot subsequently
my friend my very best friend in the
world at that time was an actor who has
become rather you know prominently known
as his name is Thomas Jane we were very
very close he auditioned wait I got into
the audition now is that is that okay
now okay all right he again this is a
little bit new for me so ya know so he
he he told me you know I met this I
auditioned for this movie about an angry
skinhead or whatever and there was this
British director and he was very
eccentric and he was in the room and he
didn't seem to respond to my audition he
was referring to the the you know the
director of Tony Kaye who directed
American history acts he said I think
this director would like you I don't
know why he just he got that sense that
somehow Tony Kaye was going to connect
with me somehow or respond to me I guess
or my my and my acting or whatever yeah
anyway so that's what life was like that
it was okay to answer your question in
short life was very difficult broke
no car no driver's license no job and
trying to get auditions it was it was
pretty tough yeah so you take Tom's
advice you walk in that door for the
auditions no what happened is is
Tom said had there dis this keys in
trying to figure out at that time they
had not confirmed that Edward Norton was
you know playing the lead part in the
movie and he was doing these cattle
calls if they I guess apparently if that
did not happen or what direction they
were going with the lead role I don't
know what they had not figured that out
yet apparently so he said they're gonna
do a cattle call they're gonna be doing
these cattle calls between New York and
Los Angeles and he was doing one there
and then doing one here and it was on
this day and I got the information and
he told me where it was gonna be and he
said you know I happen to have the
script because you know I auditioned and
I said well and he said I'll drop it off
at your house so I was in following
morning I he came in the middle of the
night I was sleeping I lived on the
first floor he put it in between my
window and left it on my TV the top of
my TV set and I woke up in the morning
and I went I started making my coffee or
whatever and I look and there is a
script on the the top of my television
set and it was just a weird moment where
I went I didn't know what that was and
why it was there it was some kind of
like Lord of the Rings moment or
something really weird like I'm really
like it was surreal because where I was
in my life at that time and what that
script wound up meaning for the totality
of my life was insurmountable I mean
because essentially what ended up
transpiring from reading that story to
the audition to then the relationship
that I had with tony kaye four or five
well for many you know for multiple
years working and since then just
keeping in touch here and there but our
we have had a relationship that has gone
for years as a result of that I just
covered a lot of ground there really
fast
I'm loving I assuring this this yes in
this apartment you I'm gonna keep going
with that please I want to know yeah how
it all went down I actually you know I
had said earlier I did not have a job
done I actually had a job answering
phones that was like I got a job way out
and like say
mónica somewhere it where I had to get
up and take the bus at five o'clock in
the morning for minimum wage to answer
the phone for this Farsi speaking
computer company and I was the only
American speaking but there were
wonderful people and they were very
religious and they were they were
amazing people and this was a you know
you have to understand being 20 24 at
the time with no money absolutely broke
you know every dollar I made it the
student this silly little job was going
to every amount of living expense I had
so there was no spare it was just a
difficult time meeting friends to help
me out and whatnot so when this audition
came up I thought this is unbelievable
because so first so let me get back to
the story though for a second of reading
that script my I had had a very long
difficult complicated you know childhood
in and out of the juvenile hall systems
and all this kind of stuff my brother's
name is Daniel Danny the when I opened
the script and I had gone through a very
similar cathartic emotional experience
in my life dramatic in nature very much
similar to the dramatic nature of the
spiritual shift in the character in the
story so when I read the script it was
overwhelming the emotion that came over
me that was not only what was going on
in my life personally at the time but
also the fact that my brother and I
meant that a lot of stuff after I became
a movie here and found the new way to
live right so it was it was a powerful
experience so I could not wait for the
opportunity to express whatever you know
these feelings were at this audition so
I had no idea what the audition was
going to be so I asked the Iranian
computer the Iranian family that ran the
company if they would allow me to leave
work because I explained to them you
know and I said and I talked the man
he's a very religious man so you can
imagine this was a like
with a very long you know with the beard
and the whole thing and I went into his
office and said sir you know if I could
go out do this things I'm an actor I've
been trying to do this he got the woman
that worked there to give me a ride he
permitted me and drove me there when I
get there there's a line going it's a
it's a building on Wilshire Boulevard
near San Vicente in that area over there
where there's a pavilions right nearby
and it was on the it was I believe on
the third floor there's a line going out
the door and everyone is getting a
number and when you walk in the building
you're greeted by the casting director
that says okay listen this is directors
you know he's a little bit you know does
things a little differently he's got a
camera set up up there he's gonna you're
gonna when your number is called you're
gonna walk in front of the camera and
you're going to you're gonna do whatever
you know whatever you do whatever I
guess whatever you're you know gonna
show Tony or whatever so now I knew this
was going to be improvisational in
nature and I had already read the script
so I knew one key pivotal point in the
story that is that there was this scene
that the lead character does to the news
cameras when he discovers that his
father's been killed his father was a
firefighter his father died so the media
is reporting him and he has this huge
emotional outburst and he's you know
he's and he's right into the camera and
he's pointing into the camera and I knew
that was in the material so what was
happening inside of the audition room
was Tony was calling people up and he
would say how do you feel about white
power go and the actor would start
talking you know I this that the other
and cut next and it was going literally
like a firing squad like that one and of
course you can imagine sitting there
aware that you're about to go up there
there's the room is full everybody's
watching everybody's audition so you can
understand there's a hundred people in
the room and everybody's watching you
get just wiped out and I said you know I
was had every
nothing to lose I figure you know anyway
he called me up I looked at him I saw
him when he walked in the room and I
thought that's about what I thought a
director looked like real tall scary
bald and intimidating presence very
interesting this man walked into the
room and I thought that's that's a
director I go up and you know I came
from a school and a man that taught
acting that was very very very intense
and he you know he pushed it to the
limit and it was about risk and you put
it all and sort of leave it all on the
field so to speak right
and the idea was that you have to commit
all the way all the way
no no hesitation make your choice and
you go launch no fear you face whatever
fears there and you spring anyway and
take it all the way as far as you can
within your choices so when it was my
turn to be called up I thought I don't
know what's about to happen here but my
heart was pounding very very fast and I
don't know what question he was going to
ask me I had had an experience the day
prior where I was sitting on the bus and
a young a young a mother and her son
were he was like two and a half and she
was I would say abusing him hitting him
and I had witnessed the whole thing and
he fell and he was crying and he was in
need and she wasn't really helping him
and then the bus came up and I was about
to say something and I didn't and I
wanted to say and I had all of these
feelings about that right so I plugged
into that that feeling from that
experience and I said I'm going to vent
the anger rage whatever if if need be
I'll use that in this in this audition
so Tony walks up and he doesn't look at
me he gets behind the camera and he he's
looking at changing the film thing or
something and my heart was beating and I
was so nervous and I I couldn't and I'll
I just looked at him and I said how you
doing man and he I go and and he looks
up and he goes fine or whatever and kind
of looks down and I go I cuz I was this
point kind of my nerves were
overwhelming me so I just said and I
don't know what this just gotta flew out
of my mouth I just in a real intense
sort of way I said do you have something
that you need to ask me you got and I
knew that got his sort of attention
there because he looked up from the
camera with a real intense look on his
face and he got real excited and he goes
how do you feel about white power
and got all excited and then I I just
well I guess I used all that and I just
you know I did the audition or whatever
and I just went for it and just I guess
I guess it went very well because they
you know I mean subsequently everything
that happened after that
changed my life because I went on to
work with him from that point forward I
was cast in the movie well I should tell
you the whole story right the whole of
the whole the whole progression of it
right
so I'm assuming you booked the role
right there oh no no no no what happened
was he was very you know I got very
intense the audition was going very well
in the sense that I connected that
emotion to that anger I had to that
mother and the rage having my own issues
with some of that stuff as a child and
putting that all in that moment I just
used that to talk to imagine that I was
talking to the media reporter that was
asking me about the dead father
in the script so I took the opportunity
to make
he talkin to me being a news reporter as
if I'm doing now the audition here into
the camera because I was talking to the
camera man that my father and and I was
just using that sort of to express the
rage that this movement of neo-nazism or
whatever is coming and were justified
and all this ignorant that I was you
know having to portray and that's how I
did that and then when he just kept
filming it and it didn't stop I just had
to keep going I didn't even I at some
point I was I was like it's a what is
this going to stop as I have to keep you
know generating this improvisation so it
was just like I and then he just and I
said he stumbled because he was holding
the tripod and then either getting he
you know he said no no keep going
getting the light getting the light
because I stopped I said you need me he
said no no no get in the light get in
the light and I just kept going and
going and then he said great I got it
and I said great I walked away and he
said hey I see said thank you
and that was I looked at him and I said
you're welcome and I floated out of
there and I get at that point I didn't
care that I had gotten the part or not I
I knew I did something do you understand
I'm saying you think ya know I know I
knew I did something of which I could be
proud and that is vitally important
especially having ongoing understanding
of how to be an actor in this business
you have to understand the difference
between obtaining the success whether
you book the part and what you actually
can be proud of what you did in the room
are actually two different things the
results will come out of for many
circumstances that are way out of our
hands but that one thing that you can do
which is a performance to be proud of or
an audition to be proud of I felt that
happened and there was a pretty neat
feeling did you take the bus back to
work or did the people come no I took
the bus back home just really floating I
didn't even get on the bus right away I
walk
to the pavilions and I just sat down
because you have to understand at this
point life was beating me right I mean I
lived in this cubical tiny 300 square
foot apartment I was just got a hold of
that little job I was just it was just
life was very very challenging at this
particular point you have all of the
insecurities you know my friends had
started to work which I was very happy
about but subsequently you start feeling
those feelings of insecurity of what you
know what what's gonna happen here where
does this go and yeah so it was a very
cathartic it was an unbelievable moment
and then you had to fill out your name
card and this whole thing and I forgot
to write my phone number so I left the
audition and I thought well that's too
bad a week went by and I I didn't hear
anything and I knew something happened
in there and so anyway I had left mind
my information three weeks has gone by
now and I've heard nothing and now at
this point I let it go but that's still
that sense that I did something well
still remain with me so I wasn't like
disappoint or anything because I had no
real expectations then I get a phone
call from Thomas Jane anyways Louie
wakes me up and he says hey man where
where what do you do what the hell are
you doing what are you doing I said what
are you talking about he said what do
you mean what am I talking about he's
they're calling they're trying to find
you you didn't put your phone number on
the audition card you idiot he said they
have been trying to get ahold of you the
director really liked your audition and
he wants to bring you in to read for
further roll the lead role at that time
I guess they had not officially signed
Edward Norton or a name actor so I guess
that was still in play for a moment
there so it was an unbelievable moment
that phone call and then like I'm you
got to get a script there you're going
in next week you're going in did
actors in New York he's gonna come in
you're going into read and it was just
crazy because I had never really
auditioned for anything I mean they had
to do with the movie just at that point
just done all plays so I didn't know
what that meant like that anyway I got I
got to say and I just worked on a day a
ninth day and night and day and night
day and night day and night and when I
went in I went in it was it was that
same scene with the firemen that they're
talking to the news reporters and it was
an extremely IIIi got there and when I
went in to read I took a breath and and
again I was there I was in the right
right you know place emotionally and it
was the audition was fantastic when well
was you know I was very emotional and
then then the Edward Norton subsequently
signs on to the movie but they they call
now Tom's manager who's not yet my
manager but who then became my manager
after that audition because you know
success has more fathers and failure has
none right so when you start succeeding
suddenly you start acquiring here that's
another thing you must prepare yourself
for to any wait that's a whole nother
conversation but keep yourself keep
yourself in line here and keep yourself
and your craft close to your heart and
don't weigh your value upon the like
whether others approve of you must be
proud of who you are and your work to
survive in this business I believe in
the long term anyway moving forward so
you booked the role that's know so I did
the audition then then they said hey
Edward sign on in the movie Edward
Norton signed on in this movie the I had
I wasn't in SAG yet I had done nothing
nothing no credits zero so this was all
for me
like a dream or something you understand
it was like I said what meaning him
being in this process at this point for
me was unbelievable like a dream who was
coming true you know from nothing
literally nothing I can't even get on a
bus on time to now I'm in a studio
auditioning for a role that was
overwhelmingly amazing feeling and yeah
so I did that and then they said they
really really responded she signed me as
a client
so she orchestrated then the next
callback which they said they're
bringing you back in so actually now I
had someone to talk to about acting it
was really bizarre I went from nothing
to now I have like a manager and like
whoa this is really weird right it was
really weird um so then I went then I
went two weeks later I I went I - Stacy
Keach is part I had auditioned they were
auditioning me for that I walk in the
room and this was definitively for my
whole entire career will be the defining
most joyous moment that I have ever
experienced in my whole artistic life
was that moment when I went to the final
callback to do the scene that Stacy
Keach does with Edward Norton in the at
his house there after Edward Norton's
come out of prison or whatever in the
movie no so I was being such a intense
young actor that acting was everything I
was so prepared and so involved in that
final callback because I knew that I was
very very close to being having my first
opportunity to be a professional actor
if you will you know that this was an
opportunity and it was close and I had
so as an intense actor and I was so
nervous that when they called my name I
had on a trench coat
was dressed like the character I had my
combat boots on my green skinhead
trenchcoat you know my wife beater I was
working out every single day and I
couldn't handle the idea of walking in
the room and talking because I knew I
wasn't gonna be able to do that I wasn't
gonna be able to walk in there and just
start chit-chatting and then get into it
I was too too there if you will so what
ends up happening is I storm in the room
now looking back in hindsight it was a
bit theatrical but how do people know
how they process it really but I I storm
I walk in the room and I declare and I
start taking off my trench coat and I
look to the casting director and I said
Who am I reading with tell me who I'm
reading with come on now I want you to
tell me right now who I'm worried
who-who am i reading with and my hand is
shaking a little like that and she
immediately gets very serious it says
yeah you ready with him you leave he'll
be taping an audition I said okay are
you ready you ready okay you guys ready
and and I just took over this sort of
all being driven by my terror obviously
my absolute fear but no it was amazing
and and then and then yeah and then they
taped it I put my feet up on the on the
desk and began the scene and then yeah
and then it went really well
and when it was over I felt like I had
done what I needed to do like whatever
it happened I trusted I breathed and I
allowed that audition to sort of flow
and I I I flip over my I flip my paper
like that and I said huh that's that's
that and they said great job Alex
although all the people tend to be a
great job great job I said great great
thank you John Morrissey or the one of
the two producers I forgot the other
one's name how taro
of me one of those two gentlemen that
produced the movie one of them said
looks to me and says so Alex let me ask
you a question do you do you have a
girlfriend and I and I thought at that
moment because I had a very bizarre
experience earlier in my journeys with a
low level B TV producer that invited me
to his house for dinner and then tried
to with his other friends and tried to
make sort of it you don't need a
not-so-subtle advance for for work and I
had to I actually did experience that
had to turn that turn that turn turn
that you know freak show away this so I
thought in this moment when he asked me
that I thought this is insane that this
is happening at this level come on
right like give me and so I said so I
rather defensively said no no I said no
I I don't have a girlfriend no but I do
have a lot of friends thinking I was
sending a message or a boundary I don't
know I was keeping it all very low-key I
didn't know what his intent was with the
question to be very honest with you but
it was a little it was a little weird
and I said he said well GGG no I'm sorry
this is how when exactly no he said I he
said you have a girlfriend I said no no
I don't have a girlfriend and I was
still you have to understand with the
character and just had done the audition
he says well do you have any friends and
I said yeah yeah I've got it got a lot
of friends and my friend had actually
driven me to the audition so I could
focus and he said well he said why don't
you go now you gotta understand the
backdrop to this I had had five years of
it had been very difficult so he looks
he looks at me and he says well why
don't you go call your friends tonight
because we're putting you in this movie
and if there is a moment in life where
you you you feel some kind of
unbelievable good fortune or a dream
come true I guess would be the
word considering the the amount of
uphill fight it is to become an actor
right to have that moment for anyone and
I don't think that ever changes for any
actor or as long as they go I think
every time you get that you got that
part there is just nothing better and
more gratifying than that moment and
yeah it was pretty incredible
you